خمسه مبادئ اساسيه قدمها جروسسي لمنع وقوع
حادث نووي فيزابوريا
اليوم يشكل خطوه في الاتجاه الصحيح فيما
يتعلق بسلامه محطه للطاقه النوويه
الدعم لعملنا بما في ذلك للمبادئ الخمسه
التي حددتها مشجع
هذا ما اعلنه المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفع اليغروسسي امام
مجلس الامن الدولي
اول هذه المبادئ عدم شن هجوم من اي نوع من
او على المحطه ولا سيما استهداف المفاعلات
او الوقود او بنى تحتيه او الموظفين
وتشمل المبادئ ايضا عدم استخدام الموقع
لتخزين اسلحه ثقيله او حشد عسكريين
وان لا تفصل المحطه عن شبكه الكهرباء وان
تتم حمايتها من اعمال التخريب
هذه المبادئ الاساسيه الخمسه حظيت بتاييد
واسع النطاق ولم يعارضها اي صوت
على حد قول المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
جروسسي اكد ان الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه تعتزم بدء مراقبه تطبيق هذه
المبادئ من خلال بعثتها في الموقع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات